[Music]
you can play Grand Theft Auto 5 on Xbox
one but until today you weren't able to
play its predecessor or any of its DLC
that's right
now you can play GTA 4 and the episodes
of Liberty City through the Xbox ones
backwards compatibility program
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more coverage of Virtua carjackings
anyone who owns GTA 4 digitally on Xbox
360 will have the game automatically
appear in their library everyone who
owns physical copies on the other hand
just needs to insert the disk into their
console and download the game on top of
that anyone who has uploaded their save
files to the Xbox 360s cloud will be
able to pick them up again on the Xbox
one and those who don't own the game
well you can just pick it up on the Xbox
store for $20 there are now more than
300 Xbox 360 games playable on Xbox one
and recent additions to the
backwards-compatible library include
lego indiana jones rock at night and
Shadows of the Damned we'll keep you up
to date as games are added but if you
want more open world mayhem like GTA 4
check out our video on the six things we
learned from the Ghost Recon wildlands
closed beta